[Applause]
you mentioned being around um
austin early were you i feel like
generic fans of music might uh compare
you and postie together
yeah just because you guys have a lot of
tattoos yeah just because we're both fat
white
boys fair enough um
like were you around post early on yeah
i mean i
uh i was friends with um post i was
friends with austin
um i was friends with them we'd ride
around in my mom's car and like
play music and we had like very similar
tastes like
we liked the same [ __ ] and early on like
you said that you could see uh
kind of people ahead of their time did
you did you see post like and be like
you know hey
this guy could be one of the biggest
artists in the world um
i didn't see that post i knew that i
knew he was a special soul
like he's a good dude he's a great guy
yeah and um
he was just a special energy and like
we'd laugh you know he's
this kid was this prior to him moving to
l.a
he moved to l.a already at the time but
like you know we just drive around my
mom's car and listen to the ipod and he
played me his stuff
and we play he was in my video his for
my first video
you know it was just weird like you know
yeah i think me and posty kind of faded
off
when uh people started comparing us and
it became weird so
like i feel like that's somebody who you
know
when you talk about like yo i was around
a lot of the biggest artists early on
like do you feel like you might have
maybe had some sort of influence on post
early on
i don't know i i don't you know i don't
know i first heard him
you probably know charlie handsome ryan
yeah i love charlie yeah so ryan like
like ryan's from phoenix where i'm from
yeah um and he had reached out to me
like when i was doing radio in tampa in
2014
or ended for 2014 and was like dude
white iverson
i'm i'm at the time ryan was telling me
he was managing post
yeah i mean everybody was uh everybody
was managing posting something
yeah rex kudo dre you know whatever
but yeah yeah it's just it's interesting
because i do feel like
you guys uh like you
like what you just said about his energy
and what i said about your energy
earlier yeah
we have we're very similar you know
we're very similar we smile a lot and
um we have similar music taste
and what we like singing and hitting
same similar melodies and you know it's
um another reason why like i'm happy at
this 80s album is because like
you can't compare me to anybody to
anybody when i when i sing the way i do
with the 80s stuff and
you know you know posters around and you
know a lot
a lot of artists you know like even with
khalid man you know
like khalid i was driving around khalid
played me his first album before he
became
anybody you know wow yeah i feel like
khalid is another one of the early
spotify success stories
exactly like i was just i was blessed
enough to be around all these artists
and